good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy happy hump day a
great day of the week a great day to be
alive Spotify unwrapped is here it's a
great day I'm going to have a good day I
don't know why but it feels like Love's
coming my way and I'm here too so true
so true I'm here too yes you are here as
well not even as well primarily tures
stop primarily you're here primarily I'm
here and it's going to be a good day I
wrote down two things that I wanted to
talk to you about on air oh wow Jump
Right In okay the first thing is the
craziest thing happened to me this
morning
okay so I was walking to work and I
walked past my old building and my route
doesn't usually take me there but I
don't know I felt
pulled and I was waving you know I saw
my one of my favorite tour men and he
came outside and we were chatting and
he's like congratul ations and I was
like on what he was like you're pregnant
I was like no I'm
not he was like what I'm like where did
you hear that he's like I don't
know people are starting Rivers about me
in my old building wow the rumor mill I
wonder where that came from I know like
it didn't come from this world of like
social media no right someone is
spreading lies about me again
okay as far as lies go they could be
saying much worse things they have but I
just thought that was interesting and
that's the craziest thing that's
happened thus far today at 9:00 a.m.
yeah and what was the second thing just
like something I found out last night
that I cannot believe you didn't tell me
oo am I in trouble no no just like
something kind of major happened to you
and you didn't share with the class do
you want to think for a second is it
about my car
yes so Shapiro Olivia's husband is in
New York for work I think he's actually
already gone but he came over last night
to see Theo and just hang out we were
talking you know about football and just
life catching up and he just very
quickly mentioned that he was able to
get this like dent out of your car using
rubbing alcohol and I was like wait not
a dent like a scratch with it that's and
I'm like wait what I knew nothing about
this car crash not a crash so here's
what happened I've been driving more
everyone Tesla and I are back together
yesterday was my first jaunt to like
relatively far and back and and I made
it but um Zach uses my car too sometimes
like cuz I prefer it and he parked my
car in the garage and it wasn't charging
so I just need to like say that cuz
sometimes you have to park it there to
charge right so you're saying like you
got in the accident in the garage and if
it hadn't been in the garage which it
didn't even need to be you wouldn't have
gotten in the accident therefore the
accident is Z's fault no I'm just saying
like he parked it in the garage so I
didn't park it there cuz you could ask
if you parked it there how come you
couldn't get it out by the way your
Tesla's like always parked in the garage
no only when it's charging and it wasn't
charging he just likes parking in the
garage sometimes but like wasn't you
know considering I might not know how to
back out and it was tight on one side
and I was squeezing through and then I
realized oh I might be like touching cuz
I didn't hear anything but then I saw
the like rubber of the garage door was
like
bending so I mean thank God Tesla
doesn't have like handles that come out
oh you were you would have been finished
so I man to get out of the garage but I
did do a little damage to the car but
chapiro said it looked brand new like
his rubbing alcohol got the the scratch
right out the scratch out but there is a
little bit of a dent I'm not going to
lie but I think there's like companies
that can just like pull the dent out I
mean you can also like take a plunger
yeah there's companies that like do that
and more professionally but it is pretty
Elementary they just like pull the dent
yeah I also see them making it worse
yeah yeah I just thought it was
interesting cuz I have been in one you
know fender bender in my life and who
was riding shotgun and in my opinion
partially to blame for the fender bender
in the shop right parking lot you and so
we just kind of have this history and
this connection and the fact that you're
you know a new driver this happened to
you and you didn't share it with me like
I'm hurt honestly I don't know I guess
I'm supposed to make a bigger deal out
of it cuz my husband was like freaking
out about the car and I just I'm just
not attached to material things like
that okay so my car has and honestly it
was about time I'm a really bad driver
yeah and I will say I've driven the
Tesla once and I did pull it out of your
garage and it was one of the scarier
moments of my life it's very tight I
don't even blame you at all new driver
old driver it's tough yeah like there's
a reason that wasn't for me but um I had
to do it I actually I don't even think
I'm a bad driver I don't drive enough to
be a good or a bad driver inexperienced
driver I'm inexperienced yeah but when
I'm out on the road it's not like I'm
terrible I'm just like nervous yeah do
you think like the other drivers can
feel that sort of nervous energy from
you cuz when I was like a new driver I
would be like everybody knows I'm new
yeah well for a while I had my sticker
on the back of my car like student
driver but then when Zach started
driving my car um he took it off and so
like I just feel like I kind of have my
training wheals off yeah and I'm just
like nobody knows what they're next to
but then I was driving with fellow
drivers yesterday and people were like
zooming past and just like everybody
seemed to really know what they were
doing and then I like looked in the cars
it's so interesting and it just like
wasn't what I thought I thought it was
you know going to be like biker Vibes
like vroom vroom I'm in my theying soul
and I'm going crazy but it's kind of
just like old people and they're like
driving just like they're driving just
like me close to the wheel we're all in
the same boat that's beautiful so you've
officially popped your your cherry and
also whenever I drive somewhere and I
arrive like I tell everyone who I'm with
like about my experience and I've
realized like so many other people have
driving things too like I talk about how
like when I'm turning I always want to
know where my next turn is so I can get
into the right lane in the initial turn
and that's kind of like something that
everybody's doing cuz we're all kind of
hating changing lanes changing lanes is
definitely the worst and I think a safe
beted is to always go in the middle yes
but if you can predict your next turn
and it's not too far down you can turn
into that lane yeah we call that a wide
turn yeah or I have to get in the left
Lan and making a left turn so I like the
test because it lets me know where my
next turn is too I'm I love that for you
a littleit cheat I was in a Tesla
yesterday MH with the nicest driver we
were so connected you
know and it was when I was with Theo I
picked him up from the vet he had a good
appointment at the vet yesterday so he
was asking me about Theo and I'm at the
point now where I just tell literally
anyone who listens about what I'm
dealing with and when we just got to
talking about cancer you know his
daughter-in-law's mother has cancer and
it's been really hard on his family and
then he told me he's from Afghanistan
and we actually talk a little bit about
Israel Palestine and it was just like a
lovely and then and then it started to
snow it snowed yesterday in New York for
all of five minutes I saw your story and
we were talking about the snow and it
was just kind of like a magical ride I
don't know I'm maybe I'm so I'm so
Desperately Seeking signs right now like
I'm taking everything as a sign I'm like
oh my God this light turned yellow when
I got here Theo's cancer is going to
slow down like I'm literally insane
Desperately Seeking signs and I but I I
do you think that that driver like he
was just he had a light about him you
know that's beautiful yeah what was his
sign or was he just there to provide
Solace he just had like this warm voice
and I don't know I he was and then he
was like telling me he's having this
issue with the customer service rep like
we were giggling like I'm telling
you maybe it was the Tesla right the amb
what kind of tesler did he have it
looked kind of just like yours but I
think it was black black of test yes
black of test so model Y is what I have
sure um Theo had a
good visit to the pet vet yesterday um
and today I found this new vet and they
have a bunch of City uh locations in the
city and at the Tribeca one no not now
You scrolling your phone when I'm giving
like a Theo update turning on do not
disturb because I don't want to be
disturbed by the is that a new phone
case is it zebra yes I didn't know if
you would notice it's not zebra so what
it is it's a highcon contr phone case
which these are the sorts of patterns
that babies like look at because they
can see high contrast colors best so
that way if I'm ever on my phone like in
Charlie's looking at me on my phone he's
actually getting an education okay that
makes total sense because other than
that it is ugly and I was like
but it's um it's it's enriching for my
son I love it it's the most beautiful
thing I've ever seen but before that I
was like oh my God it's giving like
Millennial Chevron 2008 enrichment
enrichment yeah so like if I'm like
breastfeeding I'm I'm on my phone and he
like looks up like it's not just like oh
mommy's on her oblong it's like oh look
at this a game for me oblong it's from
Clara and the sun oh okay it's like cuz
he doesn't know what a phone is so it's
just like this device course of course
okay well you know what I'm I'm glad I
asked because the more you know yeah and
the brand is masil as in marvelous misss
um if you'd like to get your own I'm so
I love that they could do like a little
bit cuter on the high contrast designs
but it's fine it's it's a moment it's
fine it's fine um so I found this new
vet and that's where we were yesterday
it's called your vetare you are vetare
and they have locations all over the
city and I was on the website yesterday
and I saw they had an herbalist and an
acupuncturist and you know I was saying
yesterday I'm really open now to all
different types of alternative medicine
so today we're going down to the Tribeca
location to get Theo seen by an
herbalist who's hopefully going to do
some acupuncture which should be really
helpful God willing you know if it if it
works correctly um for his leg pain so
I'm excited about that tury you're kind
of crunchy no I'm granola I'm crunchy
it's really there's something about like
becoming a mother makes you crunchy 100%
I went to the holistic pet store
yesterday yeah granola tur era I mean I
guess like I got to granola Life by
sheer desperation for lack of other
options I don't know if that's how
everyone comes to it but I imagine
that's how a lot of people come to it
yeah yeah definitely because it's
another option um no but I think a lot
of new mam at least like Mom friends of
mine like we all turning crunchy no and
that's Ben's Dream Ben like wants to
give up on Western medicine he thinks
it's like giving us all cancer and he's
literally like Denise Richard's husband
like he fully is like if it were up to
him like he would get strep throat and
like have a tea you know but like he
can't you know yeah no I mean he can't
deal with the like pain is it just about
medicine or is he crunchy about other
stuff too like does he make his own
potato chips in the air fryer no no no
he's not crunchy like that it's really
only about medicine like he really
believes in the power of like Chinese
herbs Eastern medicine and he's always
like trying to get me and I'm like
please just take Advil and shut the
up and he's also loves essential oils
right know he loves eucalyptus so this
like us turning to Eastern medicine for
Theo's care is Ben's absolute dream so
does he not want to be doing all the CAT
scans radiation okay he does he's not
all in no but like I could see one day
Ben becoming like a Christian Scientist
you know like they don't believe in like
Advil and stuff yeah there's more to
that I think U Marjorie post we read a
book about her her family was Christian
Scientists that's why they like made a
really healthy breakfast well I don't
judge anyone for their beliefs like
that's something I could never
do like you know how many Tums Advil
aspirin like you know many shits I
take a day not shits like poop shits
like medicines okay but I think on the
other side of the argument it's like
you're also putting a ton of into
your body all day no I'm fueling my
problems yes it's a self fufilling thing
whereas if you kind of exited from the
whole toxic ecosystem and you were
non-toxic and you made your own soap
then you wouldn't need to take Advil
because you wouldn't have these
headaches it's a self-fulfilling thing
and I've never been happier okay so
leave me alone I'm just saying like I'll
add it to the list of one day she'll
become
crunchy I'm crunchy I'm taking my son to
acupuncturist okay you're on your way
I'm on my
way speaking of Music Spotify wrapped we
have a story today so I guess we'll like
save that but that was definitely a big
part of my morning just and I actually
like have a kind of like a conspiracy my
WRA is not
accurate but that's the whole point
Jackie it's stated J in fact no I know
but I can prove
it oh my God we're blowing this thing
wide open I can prove it but I think
they might be trying to help me is I the
investigation later in the show stay
tuned stay tuned stay tuned for the
investigation oh
wow it's not bad I don't think Spotify
is doing anything bad I just feel like
they're being dishonest but maybe for a
good reason so Spotify R is obviously an
exciting time of year but I think it's
like more exciting for us because a lot
of people don't know this when you are
like a Creator on Spotify like you can
go to Spotify and search for us um you
get your own set of wrapped statistics
that I watched this morning and they're
kind of General but they they are
interesting and and they're um they're
just interesting yeah I'm excited we'll
get into them during rap shall we I
guess we also to De toaster today so
maybe we should just Dive Right In
because we have no time to waste no we
don't without further adoo Ado here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know and the fast five stories that you
need to know are brought to you by State
Farm the State Farm personal price plan
helps you create an affordable price
just for you the plan is all about being
personal to you and your needs so that
means you're getting the coverage you
want a policy that helps cover what's
important to you and an affordable price
just for you because after all life is
just better when you can personalize
your experiences so think about it like
this from your go-to coffee order to
your favorite pair of sweatpants we know
you love to personalize your entire day
just like we do let's take it from the
beginning breakfast we know Jackie you
know engorges herself on 35 of the
biggest breakfast tacos you've ever seen
in your life and me I just have like a
handful of
nuts so there's just like so many things
about our dayto days that are so
personal and what's more personal than
Insurance not comedy not poetry
personalization just makes everything
better and State Farm believes that
insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage your selections can
all be personalized to you so the next
time you are taking your Tesla out of
the garage and you scratch and dent the
back bumper like just know that State
Farm like a good neighbor like they are
there they are there for you and you can
feel good you know just pulling out of
that garage recklessly no I'm
kidding um like a good neighbor State
Farm is there prices vary by state
options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
because State Farm believes that
insurance should be personal your plan
your coverage and your selections are
all personalized by you so let me just
say that one more time in case anybody
didn't hear me like a good neighbor St
is there you want to do one like a good
neighbor State Farm is there today's
episode is also brought to you by kiwi
Co unwrap unwrap inspiration with super
fun science technology and art projects
for kids with kiwo with nine different
subscription options for different ages
and subjects there's something for every
kid now I'm not a mother but I am a very
very very involved auntie and what I
learned like spending time with kids is
that time moves slow you know you get a
big fancy toy they're into it for about
30 seconds keeping them stimulated is
extremely difficult you don't want to
always be turning to screens Ki is
low-key genius it's like fun games and
stuff but it's super educational and it
keeps these kids intrigued for long
periods of time so kiwo delivers fun
Hands-On projects that inspire a
lifelong love of learning the projects
from kiwo spark creative confidence for
ongoing tinkering and experimentation
sure you can buy a robot robot but isn't
it way more fun to build your own and
way more timec consuming next thing you
know the whole day's gone by and it's
time for bed tested and approved by kids
no crate leaves without approval from
their toughest critics the kids Ki Co
offers gifts with Rich activities for
kids of all ages an interest so give
your child the tools to learn new skills
build new experiences and make new
connections to the broader World
discover Hands-On fun with kiwo get your
first month free on any crate line at
kiwi co.co.com
toast that's kiwico
kiwi.com
toast so that's your first month free at
toast kiwico.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by game time you should not have to
worry when to buy tickets for your next
big event game time is the fast and easy
way to buy tickets for all the sports
music comedy and Theater events near you
with killer killer Trav last minute
deals all in pricing view from your
seats and their best price Guan game
time takes the guesswork out of buying
tickets game time is the only ticketing
app that gives you complete peace of
mind with your purchase see the view
from your seat before you buy so you
know exactly what to expect when you
arrive all in pricing shows your total
upfront so you know what you're getting
and you know you're getting a great deal
before you check out no more of this
finding a seat oh look these are decent
next thing you know click click click
it's Tri three times the price because
of their like you know fraudulence and
their fees no now with game time they've
got all in pricing the price you see is
the price you pay they have tickets on
they have deals on tickets right up to
the start of the event and even an hour
after it starts just a great app to have
on your phone if you live in a fabulous
City like I do and if you don't live in
a fabulous City but you travel you know
keep it on your phone you find yourself
you know in Charlotte the Bobcats
playing you'll know because game time is
alerting you to all the fabulous things
going on in the city that you're in with
game time guarantee you that means
you'll always get the best price so if
you find tickets in the same section a
row for Less game time will credit you
110% of the difference take the guess
workk out of buying tickets with Game
Time download the game time app create
an account and use code toast for $20
off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
to a St for $20 off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed thank you la you're welcome
jaui and thank you game time for
sponsoring today's episode our first
story Spotify rap 2023 is here here and
Spotify is sharing the of their most
streamed artists songs albums of the
Year globally so the most streamed
artist globally of the year was guess
Taylor Swift yes number two Bad Bunny
three the weekend four Drake five peso
pluma I think it's so crazy like every
Big statistic the weekend is on do you
know what I mean like all these list
he's always on them and like I do listen
to his music but I don't know it just
feels like so Random to me yeah I feel
that I do also the rest of the list six
is five seven Travis Scott eight siza
nine Carol G 10 lanao Del Reay it's very
interesting and this is global right
yeah this is global but it's
um I don't know some of these are are
pretty
surprising yeah and also there's some
like people I feel who are notably
missing but I guess because I'm thinking
America yeah I was trying to find the
American list but the sptify wrapped
link is like not working on like I would
have thought maybe Olivia Rodrigo would
be in
there I mean or Billy ish yeah yeah like
there are some big names that aren in
Here Beyonce oh yeah beyon and
Renaissance came out this year right
yeah so it's surprising it is now for
most stream songs globally okay number
one
flowers that's maor lying no that's
major two Kill Bill by siza wow three as
it was by Harry Styles that feels right
yeah 47 by Jung cook I don't even know
oh I don't know that I uh I think he was
in DTS yeah yeah yeah okay yeah five
Ella baas Sola by peso pluma okay six
Cruel Summer by Taylor Swift so that's
her top song of the year yes but that's
interesting like her being number one
Global artist makes total sense but
logically wouldn't then the biggest song
no because she might she has song number
six she has song number 10 she might
have 11 12 13 and Miley only has the one
right right right right right uh seven
creeping by Metro booming the weekend
and 21 Savage what if you think I know
it eight calm down remma and Selena
Gomez the only stuff I saw about come
down come down come down you for me come
down come down I don't know if I know it
I only know the drama like cuz Haley
Bieber posted a version that's not the
Selena version right right that's all I
know about the song nine
Shakira
song and 10 anti-hero Taylor Swift okay
very interesting I mean this is
obviously the year of Taylor Swift so
none of this is surprising to me but
honestly flowers that's that's huge yeah
Miley must be freaking like this is I
feel like success musically that she's
really been like searching for for a
while and she's had like major Bops in
the last you know 5 10 years but this
like a global hit yeah yeah and then for
most streamed albums of the Year first
Bad Bunny wow yeah but I guess he was
off of that all that last list so he
needed to make up for it in order to be
the number two artist right two
midnights by tailored Midnight's become
my afternoon three SOS by siza yeah no
when we were talking about Grammy
nominations and stuff like SEL might
sweep yeah and she would be right to
because the songs are really good but
also they have like such commercial
success and I think it needs to be a
mixture of both yeah for Star Boy by the
weekend oh my God the weekend is an
industry plan like I know he's really
famous not everybody knows who he is but
the weekend is an industry plan like let
me ask you a question anybody like if I
have a playlist or whatever like maybe
there's a weekend song on there and I
always hear them on the radio and you
know restaurants and stuff but has
anybody like ever gone to Spotify and
searched like the weekend just to Listen
to Only the weekend I feel like no
clearly people but but I don't want to
diminish like he's extremely talented I
thought his Super Bowl performance was
very good like he he is that but
like part of this feels planty I agree
planty mplant like he's just on every
list all the time yeah five Carol G six
one thing at a time by Morgan Wallen
seven
lover eight heroes and villains by Metro
boomman nine Genesis by peso pluma 10
Harry's house by Harry Styles well and
Harry's house didn't even come out this
year so that's super impressive
yeah wow statistics are so interesting
who was your number one artist Luke
Holmes he's every song of mine who was
yours so mine was Taylor Swift but then
my top four songs were Luke Holmes you
know what my number one song was what
Joe oh I feel that you're always talking
about Joe I love that song but also it
was the first lukol song we had gotten
in a while so I must have listened to it
so many times my first my top four out
of five are Luke Holm songs and my first
one is still which I love oh but it
wouldn't come to me as like my it's
probably my third favorite song on the
album that's like not a single uh so
it's just it must have been in the order
in which it was on um in the album and
and in my like songs I just kept playing
it I do had a hot take about wrapped oh
okay wait hold on I want to hear the
rest of your rap my one was still two
growing up and getting old but that's
also cuz it's the first song on the Luke
album so every time I went to press the
album right that started it three you
found yours which I would say is one of
my favorites from the album and for take
you with me of course okay so my all
five songs oh no four out of five were
Luke number one was
Joe So Random I'm like not like a sober
queen or anything it's a song about
sobriety two every thing I love by
Morgan Wallen that feels right mhm three
growing up and getting
older is that the first song on the
album that's what I just said yep four
you found yours that's definitely one of
my favorites from the album and five
love you anyway from Luke Holmes as well
love and then my top artists one luk
Holmes two let me guess I was G to say
two Taylor Swift three Morgan Wallen
he's four right he's four who would
three be I don't is it like a kids thing
no who is it Mimi web oh I was not going
to guess that yeah and then five you
could guess who's my
queen Megan no oh my big Kelly
Clarkson oh right of course of course of
course so honestly I feel obviously like
it's data what's your top genre uh pop
oh mine's contemporary country
contemporary country was my second which
is interesting so my top artists was
Taylor Swift Luke Holmes Morgan Wallen
Kelsey ballerini and then the fifth I
was like shook by The
1975 like I definitely got I definitely
got into them this year but I don't know
probably more than five songs I must
have listened to those five songs a lot
or I literally don't listen to anything
other than my top four artists that like
they just threw one in there yeah yeah
um so then where my Spotify rap went
wrong I went to my top songs and I was
also very worried this year that my my
Spotify rap would be infiltrated by kids
music because like Harry wants to listen
to one song we listen to wheels over I
thought wheels on the bus was going to
be like my top five for sure and it's
not even on my
playlist so maybe they are doing
intentionally taking off kids songs like
cuz there's a couple like that that are
you know that I listen but then at the
bot like towards the end of my playlist
Daisy Bo Peep has lost her sheep is on
there which we maybe listen to like
We only listen to it when we listen to
the whole Mickey album so maybe like a
lot of the Mickey and wheel songs become
ineligible for wrapped but they forgot
that one you know no and also Donald
went to courton from the Mickey Mouse
album but it's like if you're going to
put anything from the Mickey Mouse album
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse or hot dog like
we listen to those a million times yeah
so I'm just saying I mean I appreciate
that they didn't like ruin my playlist
but Donald went to courton that's Zach's
favorite song not mine do you want to
hear some of our toast podcast
statistics always so we had an episode
this year that 3% of our new listeners
started listening to on this particular
episode and they stayed with us and that
was our episode on October 7th about
Israel which kind of makes sense because
it's like a kind of a diversion from
what we normally talk about so it makes
sense that we'd find a new audience
there yeah but it's also very
heartwarming that because you would
worry that if we talk about such serious
subjects that that would you know deter
people cuz this is a fun up show but no
you guys rock with us thank you and you
sent it to your friends and family we
were listened to in 133 countries Global
obviously the United States was our top
country with 94% of our total streams
being from the United States but our
listener our our countries go as such
United States Canada UK Australia
Ireland and we're always offending them
I know I'm always like up Irish
history I won't do it anymore I'm really
sorry our most shared episode of the
Year October 7th but our most streamed
episode of the year which makes a lot of
sense was August 4th our final episode
before your maternity leave that does
make a lot of sense we charted for a
total of 40
weeks the other 12 well no no well I
feel like it's all of them because the
weeks like starting now don't count
towards wrapped true and then we plus
maternity leave we were off month weart
we chart it every week we are in the top
10% of charting podcasts
we could work on that I don't know what
that really means no it's like of wait
hold on of the ones that chart we're in
the top 10% okay that's pretty good I
thought it was top 10% of podcast I'm
like we can get better no of ones that
chart so of the elite of the elite we
are top 10 okay we saw some nice growth
this year 112% increase in streams
that's a lot I know I was shook by that
and we are a top podcast like we are the
number one show for for 250,000 people
that's crazy especially cuz most of our
listeners don't listen on Spotify right
and most of our listeners listen to a
lot of other shows like we might we they
might listen to us but they also
probably like maybe they have a
different favorite podcast but we are
the favorite right that is crazy but
also maybe some maybe those are some
Apple users too who like when the
episode didn't go to Apple one day they
listened on Spotify and now it's their
number one show on Spotify so I find
those wrapped data Graphics from the
Spotify for creators account that we
have I find that more interesting than
like my personal music taste like I
could have told you my personal music
taste fascinating stuff no I like to see
my personal music tast he like is it
what I think it is or am I secretly
listening to a ton of something but I
don't identify as a that person fan you
know what I mean right no I do but no
I'm very consistent like Luke through
and through Luke it was a luky
year as it was yes the luks where luks
luks comes luk Luke's Combs and what I
also like about Spotify wrapped is like
we all know what's coming every year but
they always like sneak it up on us it's
not like we know what's coming early no
it like drops in the middle of the night
and it's so exciting to wake up to and I
like that I like it too what are your
thoughts on a people sharing on their
Instagrams their own personal WRA I'm
okay with it as long as I'm interested
in you which is really like anything
else and then what are your thoughts on
you know podcasters or like creators
sharing however many times they got
tagged and like someone being like Yay
the toast is my like I shared a few this
morning on the toast maybe three or four
but I think maybe I'll stop there no I
love it it's nice it's nice I love it
and also when other podcasters do it
when I've seen it like when they share a
bunch I'm I'm impressed so like yeah why
not us impress okay dress to impress
tury L okay yeah no it doesn't B like if
there's an influencer who I like yeah I
want to see what you got down to this
year what are you about cool cool I just
feel like no one would be surprised by
what we're about because we're such
consistent genuine influencers authentic
right right
right right are you ready for our next
story someone who didn't make Spotify
wrapped um Casey Musgraves and her PO
poet boyfriend Cole Schaefer have broken
up after two years of dating I didn't
even know they were still together like
I remember them being spotted and then
like it was over so I thought they were
over you know nobody ever the paparazzi
caught them and then never followed them
around so I just thought like it was a
one time deal no they were together they
had a blissful romance for 2 years but
it's come to an end source is told page
six that the relationship has been over
for at least a month and say it's all
the buzz in Nashville where the former
couple resides they've even stopped
following each other on
Instagram
um cool I love Casey mus Graves I kind
of wanted more for her in her next
relationship you know maybe someone like
on her level Fame wise
so I'm not going to cry tears over this
I do want Queen to be happy and I think
a breakup is good for you know the
creative choices yeah so I think we'll
be getting good music out of it but I'm
not going to you know no love loss for
me yeah yeah I don't know him um maybe
they wrote some nice poetry together
maybe he was helpful for her art Liz
Woods did like a funny thing on her
Instagram story about this like how can
you be a poet full-time like in this day
and age like how do you make a living
off of being a poet you could write
greeting cards you could write a book of
poetry I guess a book well let's look at
his
work like you get
published like where do they publish
poetry like if you're a writer like
short stories you know they put you get
your short stories published in like in
big magazines they pay you for that like
how do you make money as a poet um you
could ALS maybe like literary magazines
yeah he said on his website um I'm a
multi-hyphenate writer s Slinging Ink in
a number of different genres ranging
from poetry short fiction Memoir and
spoken word oh okay so he's more of a
writer than a poet yes and I don't want
to I'm just like accustomed to never
clicking someone's LinkedIn link because
like then they see it but like why would
I care if he sees I'm not even logged
into LinkedIn I don't even have a
LinkedIn um I think he has a
job he's a creative director and
copywriter for honey
copy oh he's got a job yeah and then he
has a really long about him like that
that I think is a a sample of his
writing oh okay okay that's nice are are
you interested you don't no no please
please I'm literally begging you with
every fiber of my being not to read that
like for real there's a screen
separating us it's the same screen
separating you and the people that could
be your customers it's everywhere it's
beautiful it's giving AI generated it's
staggering what a boot costs it's packed
full of endless opportunity but
it doesn't come without a few
drawbacks leave it there I'll leave it
at
that um so let's play a game and maybe
we should add her to our list she's a
very eligible girly and I didn't even
know that she'd been in a two-year
relationship so she probably should have
been on the list before but now she's
officially single so who can we set her
up with let's see who's available Keenan
Thom she doesn't like to date famous
people maybe not yet maybe she's had
enough of
like oh you know who I could see her
with who Bill
hater honestly because she looks like
all the girls he's previously dated like
Rachel bson same
Vibes yeah uh Josh grin even though he
has a girlfriend wait Casey mascar and
Josh grin is the greatest couple of all
time think of the music think of the
music somebody needs to set them up even
though I believe he's in like a very
committed relationship yes he is but I'm
leaving him on the list
no ring no
list um
Keenan Keenan and
Casey I'd like to believe that these two
honestly CU honestly like Casey's kind
of
goofy when I say ye you say ha you know
yeah she is Goofy but I also think she's
so serious and no I don't think it would
work I don't think there's anyone on the
list for
her what about Jo man Janell
even though he's with someone and I
think they're having a
baby all yeah I think I saw that too so
maybe not but
like no there's no one on the list for
her I agree with you it's going to be
you know an artist um right like a
Taylor Swift formerly
maybe honestly totally no I feel like
she could eat him for breakfast no
totally that's the funny is saying
eating him for breakfast yeah yeah but
like you know exactly what I mean of
course you would eat him for
breakfast Nom Nom Bon appe
petitte are you ready for our next story
yeah what' you have for lunch
yesterday I went from here to the
vet oh no I don't uh no I don't know
what you had I had Ian and I don't know
why it's so hard I think I had uh
turkey turkey
turkey yeah I had a light lunch and then
I had like a big delicious dinner I made
egles dinner egg noodles I made egg
noodles which is one of my favorite
things to eat and I did like fancy so I
drained the egg noodles I put them back
on the stove butter cheese Rayos oh wow
it was really good yum yeah I did that
my eyes twitching so bad
like just keep it closed I need to get
an eye patch honestly okay I'm going on
like three weeks of this ey
twitch I'm sorry and it always shows up
at inopportune times you
know yeah are you ready for our next
story which is some relationship news
yes Megan fahe and Leo w share a kiss at
the Bowery Hotel so the two White Lotus
3 co-stars couple uh couldn't keep their
hands off each other Monday night at New
York City's Bary Hotel so these two are
confirmed together and I didn't watch
their season but were they a couple no
no he was he was with that annoying
wench Porsche but they were both on
White Lotus season 3 so this is an onset
romance yeah but I don't think they
literally had One Singular scene
together so I don't even know when they
would have met in the
presss yeah no I'm obsessed he's so
handsome and I just watched an episode
of Gossip Girl and Megan fahe was a
character who was she Chuck was trying
to get a meeting with this like big time
businessman and she was his assistant
and she ended up being like a like a
sleuth wow yeah it was kind of amazing
that's a great thing about Gossip Girl
because it was so long ago and it
launched many careers like there are a
lot of people on it um Jessica Pearson
from Suits plays Vanessa's Mom oh and I
also just got to the part I did not know
like Hillary Duff had like a four
episode Cameo where she plays like a
famous person who dates Dan sure um and
ends up having a spoiler alert threesome
with Dan and Vanessa like me and Ben
were like this is not real I did not
remember any of this happening I
remember that and when we first saw her
in the first episode that she was on I'm
like oh okay she did an episode no she
had like an arc she had a multi-episode
Arc she was on the show
casted it was shocking now I'm I'm very
deep into Gossip Girl and I think I can
make some generalizations if I will sure
hands down it's a tie for who the worst
character is Serena
Serena and or Jenny Humphrey it just
depends like she gets good and then she
gets bad but she's really just an awful
awful person yeah best character player
I mean Blair but honorable mention
honestly Lily and
Rufus yeah Lily okay Rufus is really the
moral compass of the show yeah and when
you watch it as a kid maybe you're like
he's annoying like let the kids be kids
but he's an amazing dad and facts
everything he says facts like no you
can't go to you know butter water laara
in the middle of the night like the kids
are nuts they're always just going
places and Lily she's like a little bit
more relaxed but she's a very okay so I
just got to the episode where Serena is
dating Army
Hammer and Army Hammer is this big Tech
guy and he's raising money and so Serena
invites him to the co-op board meeting
of Lily and rufus's building so he can
pitch people
so I think he literally ends up getting
a million dollars from like a bunch of
different people and that night he runs
away with it just like Chuck and Blair
said he would right so Serena's freaking
out trying to fix this herself and
Lily's like no because if people find
out about this you're going to look like
a fraud conoman so what I'm going to do
is tell everyone that the investment
fell through and give them their money
back and I will pay it off personally
Queen what a thing to do and of course
Ser is like no Mom I can fix this she oh
God I can't with Serena and I
just got through the trip episodes where
she's a dumb and a half and then
that right after the whole trip thing
she's dating Nate I can't with these
people Serena is the worst
Serena's the worst at I think because
she's like meant to be like a sweet
we're supposed to like her but I think
she's so reckless but Jenny is like
obviously the worst but we all hate her
like she's and she has bad intentions
like she is evil Jenny Serena's just
annoying and just dumb and just
really thinks she knows best yeah I like
I'm at the point where Chuck and Blair
are together and I know that cuz I
remember she ends up almost marrying
this Prince so I know that they break up
at some point soon and then of course
they're endgame but they don't make it
easy for us the whole time but I'm just
really loving living in Chuck and Blair
being together and like living together
and he's this businessman like I just
love it I know it's going to end soon
but I love it yeah yeah okay are you
ready for our next story yeah so a
little almost casting news you probably
haven't heard my favorite my favorite
news Bradley Cooper wanted Howard Stern
to play his brother in A Star is Born
the role eventually went to Sam Elliott
you know him 1883 mustache man um but he
wanted Howard Stern to shave his head
and take the role is Howard Stern an
actor a patron of of the Arts well he
had his movie he did yeah there's like a
movie based on his book it was like a
biopic and he played
himself people say that we say the word
biopic wrong it's
biopic and that's just never going to
work for me it's a biopic potato potato
because it's biographical so biopic it's
a bio and it's a picture biopic biopic
uh no that sounds like a s of s surgery
having a biopic biop yeah so no Theo
we're going to get him a myopic biopic
yeah it's biopic eat my
ass agreed um so yeah he almost played
the half brother manager but Sam Elliott
crushed it like he's was amazing so this
doesn't Hur no not at all but I did see
a bunch of clips from this interview
it's obviously Like Making Waves and
Howard Stern asked Bradley Cooper would
you rather for this uh he's doing with
Carrie Mulligan is it the Leonard
Bernstein film is that what he's doing
press for yeah is it that's already out
he I don't know if it's out yet but
that's what he's doing all his press
for just what is Bradley Cooper and
Carrie Mulligan doing together okay and
he's also directing what would Carrie
Mulligan be doing in the
movie
Maestro is that has to be about Leonard
Bernstein he's a music
composer uh the graceful portrayal of
Felicia Bernstein yeah okay so he said
and I guess Bradley Cooper's directing
it wow a movie about a Jewish man not a
Jew and it um I'm like yeah that's what
I was saying what is Carrie Mulligan
doing in a Jewish like give it to Alex
Bornstein like give it to someone um so
he and obviously it's a film that's very
close to Bradley's heart he's directing
it I think he was really involved in it
so he said would you rather win the
Oscar for Bernstein have Carrie Mulligan
win the Oscar and you also win the Oscar
for best director
or the Eagles win the Super Bowl and he
said the Eagles really he didn't even
Flinch he was like no question I don't
believe him duh I mean how like vapid
would he be if he said the first one
well no but also the Eagles winning
their their sports game like when you
really Whittle it down it's a game well
no I mean you could say the same for
both like these are like you know Rich
actors like acting for millions of
dollars beings that they just Pat
themselves on the back for it no but
they're both they social constructs
they're both social
constructs no the Super Bowl is not a
social construct actually it's the
opposite because it's based on numbers
like there's no there's no strategy or
formula for why someone wins the Oscar
over someone else okay I understand what
you're saying but in the sense that
like they the Super Bowl itself like is
a social contract that we've all propped
up but I agree no it's not it's because
it's literally based on winning like
it's based understand what you're saying
I understand what you're saying but
you're just not understanding what I'm
saying that's entirely possible
POS
regardless that's very interesting and I
just feel like he will look like a loser
if he had said the first one it's like a
funnier more relatable answer to say the
second one but don't get it twisted
that's not the truth that's crazy that
that bird seed movie is out and that
it's out now like yikes for Bradley
Cooper yikes for Bradley Cooper like
championing one of the greatest Jewish
musicians of all time and dating Gigi
haded one of the largest known
anti-semites of our time like it's the
math ain't mathing for for me and I know
his the Leonard burn seed family was not
mad about the nose but I thought the
nose was literally the most unnecessary
thing ever like Leonard Burn scene
didn't literally has the same exact nose
as Bradley Cooper's god-given nose like
yeah a little traumatic but also like
the nose is just is not our biggest
problem right now so I'm not going to
like get into the nose isn't our biggest
problem right now Gigi Hadas right right
I don't even care about the nose but
like the burn steam family what are you
doing yeah no I don't know it's all
weird I wonder if gig will go to the
premiere it's so weird like Leonard
Bernstein's whole thing was Israel
loving Israel he went to Israel in 1967
when they were at War to play for the
troops of Israel because he wanted to
support Israel because he believes in a
Jewish State like it's no it's the M
talking about this the weirdness more I
didn't that's why I was shocked that
Bernstein is what's coming out now cuz
like how no it's so true they should
premere the film in
Israel that is crazy know I
know I wonder if it's any like good or
accurate or I'm sure it's good I don't
know Napoleon's not oh you you heard it
wasn't good Napoleon yeah the reviews
are in and it's like it's bad abysmal
it's bad yeah and it's like an a front
to Napoleon and his legacy I think and
like just like not a yeah
bad wow so it can be done it can be bad
it can be that's so true are you ready
for our fifth and final
story am I ready for our fifth and final
story I think you are oh okay I think
you're ready because it's something that
we were talking about
yesterday sort of but Mark Cuban is
selling his majority state in Dallas M
I'm so glad you're bringing this up
something's going on with Mark cubin and
we have to get down to the bottom of it
but okay here's what's key because I
sent this right when I saw it I sent it
to Zach because he's obviously a huge
Mavs fan and he said that Mark will
still have like shares in the franchise
and will still be running the team but
he's not the majority own no he's
selling it to the adelon family Israeli
we love what do that sound that was uh
the press conference about okay yeah now
I want to know if these two pieces of
information that were dropped on
back-to-back days are like is it
coincidence no Mark Cuban is
restructuring his business something's
going on with Mark cubin I find this so
interesting because I feel like you know
he's super successful and I wouldn't
even say that the Dallas Mavericks is
his biggest you know money earner
because he has so many billion dollar
companies but it's the thing he's most
proud of of and I think it's the thing
he's most like in love with and I think
it's also the thing he's most known for
fame wise maybe he's taking a step back
from
Fame because both of these things are
like the two things we know him for fame
wise sharks and the Mavericks the Sharks
versus the Jets or he has a huge project
coming up that he needs all of his time
and he needs money like billions cuz
they bought it uh 3.5 billion was the
value
for the
team no I'm so intrigued by this this is
fishy
fishy yeah or like I think I saw a
comment like maybe he's trying to take
time away to spend more time with his
family and enjoy his success which I I
love that and that would be my reason
too but but why do you have to sell the
team why not continue on like no it
sounds like his new job is more you know
involved if there is a new job right
most owners just own the team like they
bring in management and GMS like they
don't spend all day working on the
strategy yeah but I think that he's
always done that and he loves doing like
that's what makes him part of the
Mavericks as opposed to other owners who
just own he does don't even know their
names he does oversee the basketball
operations like he's intrinsically tied
to the Mavericks whereas other owners do
they just like you know oh this is my
team say
hello yeah say hello to my little team
it's you know what it is it's
interesting it's interesting and I feel
like there will be more news about what
Mark Cuban is doing because he's
obviously I think it's a restructuring
of the business I do and then when I
heard that he sold it to the adelon
family I wanted I wanted to refresh my
memory you know how did the adelen
family make their fortune and you know
it's never what you think charter
buses I like I feel like we're thinking
too small you know about how to become
billionaires like it's always the random
you think we're thinking small or
we're thinking too
big no I think we're thinking like you
know obviously like Tech Lottery small
yeah you got to think random like
remember when we were in Turks and Kos
and we did that jet ski tour and we
passed this enormous house and the jet
ski leader was like oh that house
belongs to some guy and we're like oh
how you know who is he he's like he
literally has a patent on a door it's
always the random yeah we got to
get a door patent
yeah instead we're doing this right like
trying to be famous when it's never
going to
happen
um so yeah all right well the show's not
over yet because we have deer toaster
which I'm excited about which are
brought to you by skims we want to tell
you guys about underwear that we're
obsessed with it's the fits everybody
collection from skims and we feel like
it's their best kept secret the feeling
is like no other underwear that we've
worn before it's very stretchy important
and soft it just kind of melts onto your
body and you forget you're wearing it we
love it and we think everybody should
experience this level of comfort skims
is just a great brand a trustworthy
brand they are creating the next
generation of underwear for everybody so
I love all I mean I talk a lot about the
bralettes and the bras from skims how
they really really helped my back I
stand by that they create products for
women women real women busty women you
know that means we need comfort but we
also need support so the bras from skims
a favorite I love the racer back
bralette I also it's the fits everybody
want I also just love their t-shirt bras
that's what I wear almost every day
Jackie I know your boobs are like always
changing with motherhood you know
they're big they're small they're here
they're there um and skims has just been
a great resource for us honestly for
pre-post anti partum anti Hood yeah no
they're the best things to wear around
the house but I'm in my era of out of
the house too I love the bretts so cozy
Jackie's bralette that you like is the
scoop bralette mine is the racer back
bralette the fits everybody collection
of underwear the fits everybody
collection of underwear is super
lightweight and it molds to your body
The Buttery soft fabric stretches to
twice its size without ever losing shape
meaning you get a get get a perfect fit
every time they have it from extra extra
small to 4X so believe the hype skims is
over 90,000 F star reviews for a reason
the fits everybody collection and more
perfect fit Essentials are available now
at skims.com plus we're getting you free
shipping on orders of over $75 after you
place your order be sure to let them
know that the toast sent you select
podcast in the survey and be sure to
select the toast in the drop- down menu
that follows today's episode is also
brought to you by manscaped Mary balls
Miss from our friends at manscaped
ladies the holidays are approaching and
what if we told you that the perfect
gift does exist Santa's helpers have
been working hard to bring you manscapes
brand new performance package 5.0 Ultra
for the man in your life who doesn't
love the gift of smooth balls okay I
wanted to say I was hoping we were
having a manscaped ad soon because
obviously manscaped is fabulous I'll
tell you all about their products Ben
loves the ear nose and hair ear ear nose
ear and nose trimmer the beard trimmer
everything but we recently used our
manscape for something new and it was
amazing and that was when we had to
shave Theo's but hole we have shaved
actually a lot of his body just to keep
it clean while he's doing these
treatments and let me tell you Theo
didn't even move he didn't even feel it
it was so smooth and I just think that's
a ringing endorsement I thought it worth
metion so the performance package 5.0 is
a bundle for the man in your life who
deserves it all so the lawn mower five
5.0 the weed whacker 2.0 that's the ear
and nose trimmer and they're liquid
formulations plus you're getting two
free gifts when you get the performance
package 5.0 so the gift of manscape
doesn't stop there the B bundle comes
with two free gifts the manscaped
boxers and the shed 2.0 toiletry bag men
like don't have pouches like we do and
they need them and this is the one get
20% off in free shipping with code toast
manscaped.com that's 20% off with free
shipping at manscaped.com use code toast
gift him manscaped and unwrap your
favorite present this year code t o
manscaped.com all right are you ready
for deer toaster which is our weekly
advice segment where once a week usually
Wednesdays depending on programming we
will answer some of your inbound
inquiries a lot of you guys need advice
from us so dear toasters gmail.com is
where you can send your submissions you
can also go to the toast podcast.com
there's a little box there it's
Anonymous we'll never include your name
totally safe with us and we've got three
unique ones today are you ready
yeah I'm not I can't find it where Pages
app I don't ever understand this
thing uh okay oh I thought this one was
interesting ready mhm hi Jackson Claude
I'm writing to get the opinion of two
proud Jewish Queens on something my
husband and I have been talking about
lately we are gay he's Jewish and I was
raised Christian but his Temple has been
nothing but welcoming and lovely we are
part of their Interfaith program you two
man two yeah they're gay that's what gay
means you know for sure but I just
assume this was a woman just cuz I it's
usually a woman and I'm like man and
woman gay okay so he's Christian man has
been can you read that sentence again
we're gay I'm ready to get the opinion
of two proud Jewish Queens on something
my husband and I have been talking about
lately we are gay he's Jewish wish I was
raised Christian his Temple has been
nothing but welcoming and lovely and we
are a part of their Interfaith program
that's the cutest thing I've ever heard
yeah we always knew that we wanted to
raise our kids Jewish and with
everything going on in the world you
know it's now Progressive to want Jews
wiped from the face of the Earth we are
more Resolute than ever the only thing I
am struggling with is do you think
there's going to be a disconnect later
on with my kids with me not being Jewish
is that going to be an important part of
their identity that I miss out on
sincerely an Interfaith toaster so
they're going to raise their kids Jewish
but I don't think is planning on
converting got it so I don't have
personal experience with this but I feel
like we know people and I have friends
and like you've heard stories like I
don't think that that there will be a
disconnect if there is no disconnect if
like it's just something if you're all
about it just like they are it will just
be like oh my dad is Jewish and my dad
is not Jewish and plenty of kids grow up
like that and grow up to be proud Jews
it's just about what you teach them no
and the cool thing is it's like you can
always convert like if you do find down
the road that you feel like left out or
something or like there is a disconnect
just come here like it's it's always
something you can do you don't have to
do it now but it's like a backup plan
totally this sounds so nice like I'm
obsessed yeah and if you're like in the
Interfaith program and you're taking
them to synagogue and that's just like a
part of your life I think there will not
be a disconnect me neither as long as
like you take it seriously and like you
have respect and love for the faith
which it seems like you do right I think
your kids are very lucky to have both of
you and you sound great
great that was nice um okay next one I'm
having trouble with my iPad
today happens to the best of us I wanted
I wanted to choose Oh I thought this one
was interesting I keep saying that dear
Jackson try hi girlies I recently
decided to get sober I'm going about
four months strong I'm planning my
wedding festiv festivities this year and
I was wondering if I could get your
advice on how to approach my
bachelorette party all of my friends
will be in attendance love to drink and
I want them all to still feel like they
can drink and have fun but I'm concerned
how they will be with me not drinking in
the overall Vibe of The Bachelorette
weekend any advice on how to approach
this thanks so much and love you dearly
I feel like it doesn't need to be an
approach at all like I feel like when
anyone goes on a bachelorette party like
they are going to do what they want to
do because you still have to remember
like it's their vacation they paid for
this like I'm not not drinking for one
person or drinking for another person
like I'm me I'm going to do what feels
right to me so I think as long as they
know like do whatever you want whether
that's drink a lot or a little and it's
just a overall
place where everyone can just do
whatever they want I don't think there
needs to be like rules set in no I have
two things three things to say one I do
think you should tell your friends like
by the way I'm totally comfortable like
I want you to have fun this is like for
all of us because I think they're
probably thinking well we're going on a
b r party but she's sober what should we
do what's appropriate we don't want to
be disrespectful so I think you can tell
them how you're feeling also I would
just caution a little bit because bat
parties are like notoriously you overc
consumption Vibes and it's only been
four months and I think if you don't
want people to drink like I think that's
okay too because there are ways to have
bachette parties like you could do a spa
weekend yeah is she sober or she just
hasn't been drinking I recently decided
to get sober and I'm going four months
strong okay so that's amazing but like
you could also do like a low-key Spa
weekend there's a million different
things you could do for a bachette party
that don't include drinking so I would
just think I would think hard about like
if you think you're ready for that it's
a it's a lot but I would also be okay
with everyone just showing up as they
are like if people want to not drink out
of respect to you like that's really
nice and they should do that and if they
want to drink what you want them to
drink then that's good too like yeah
it's there's nothing bad no I would just
like think very hard about separate
thing about your decision you're doing
it like for them or for you yeah because
you want to be like buzz kill bride but
like honestly I feel like when you go on
a lot of about trette parties if
somebody was like we're going to do like
a low-key one that's like going to be
you know still really nice we're going
to go to a gorgeous Spa but like it's
it's not going to be drinking heavy I'd
be like thank God yeah a break I would
be so down right so people might
surprise you yeah but I guess my advice
would be like if you really really are
like you feel very strongly that you are
ready for this just tell them like by
the way it's not weird like do you we're
going to have so much fun it's kind of
how like so many people like have one
night stands and like hook up with
people on bachelorette parties when the
bride fundamentally cannot do that right
right the other girls are always going
to be
rowdier right
okay ready for our third one
mhm oh okay this one was funny I'm
writing in because something
horrifically embarrassing happened to me
and I need advice but I mostly need to
unburden myself after a long day of work
I will often go home and take the edge
off with a little weed pot marijuana
whatever you will while I'm high I just
usually like scroll on my I smoke she's
not giving up
smoke while I'm high I'll usually just
I'm not going in that smoke by the way I
said it with the same whoa I'm not going
in that Lake
intonation while I'm high I'll usually
scroll my phone mindlessly doing random
about a month ago I did partake
in my after workor Retreat and I was
doing the usual scrolling through my
phone and also having a side
conversation with my roommate I was
scrolling on Instagram just basically
liking every photo that went by little
did I know the entire time I was
mindlessly scrolling and liking I was on
someone's profile liking yes every
single photo of hers this girl is
someone I met in college but honestly we
were never friends and I can't even
remember a conversation that we've had
so she had to have gotten at least 50
not 50 notifications for me liking every
single one of her Instagram photos
literally mortifying and I'm just like
haunted by it I had to Ed myself thanks
ladies love you yeah that's an unburden
yourself there's no solving this there's
only releasing it there's only releasing
it but also maybe that this should just
help you like think critically about who
you follow like why are you following
some girl from college who you've never
even had a conversation
with like you need to protect but it's
almost better that it happened with
someone that she doesn't have to answer
to like no but okay let's say this was
like you know someone you're close with
or you can be honest with and they're
like the next day they're like what the
hell but then five
people and you know what keep your
circle close yeah like if you keep your
circle hella close nothing really
embarrassing can happen to you that's
the lesson for me always yeah but I do
follow a bunch of you like to
follow people you used to know on
Instagram that's how you have a a second
Instagram account that's completely
Anonymous like a normal person I thought
that you detoxed from your Fina I
actually did I'm like clean I'm like two
months clean on my Fina I thought about
it the other day I used to literally
check it once a day I was not okay and I
actually feel better for real and I did
I naturally stopped using it and it's
not like I was like I'm quitting yeah I
feel amazing I know I can't I really
can't talk about no cuz I feel like for
a Fina it's either people that like you
hate and so you're like looking at them
to hate on them and that's not healthy
or it's like people that you're like
kind of clowning on
but you find yourself like engaging all
their content you're their fan and you
should just follow them from your real
account is how I feel like if it's
really just to like hate follow like
you're a fan it's okay just follow no
the fan the hate like the hater to Fan
pipeline is extremely small MH it's
literally just but then there's the
other sect of FAA where it's your
enemies that you're checking in on
that's that's just unhealthy you
shouldn't follow those people from your
personal you shouldn't keep up with that
keep up with them at all cuz then you're
just holding on to that yeah so um when
it comes to like actual tactical advice
for you there's no advice it's LOL um it
happened good thing you it's really it's
it's harmless harmless just let I'm sure
if you told her the truth she'd be like
lol you know what is she a narc yeah
watch she's a
cop well that's dear toasters our weekly
advice segment where you girlies can
write in about truly anything and we'll
do our absolute best to help you you in
your time of need and if we have helped
you in your time of need and you have an
update for us please send us we are
waiting for you to send us an update
just write us an email dear toasters
gmail.com and put update in the search
bar in the subject line like we're
waiting for you the toasters are waiting
for you and it's kind of rude to like
take our advice and just run away and
like live happily ever after like what
happened yeah that
kapaso yeah that's our show toes wrapped
toes trapped oh that's totally the name
of today's episode oh I feel like we
might have called it that last year when
we talked about well we are consistent
yeah maybe we're consistent except we're
110% up in streams oh yeah toast wrapped
oh yeah oh yeah did we call it that last
year H uh no I don't see any a show
called toast wrapped well toast wrapped
it is y'all thank you guys so much for
listening to the toast M Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
Spotify iTunes Stitch public radio radi
cast box all the places by listen to
podcast find a beautiful standing and
goodly talented we are have a great day
we'll see you in the latter half of the
week that's tomorrow can't wait love you
love you
bye